[Musique]
l'histoire commence à cuba avec des
canadiens des américains
ils disent qu'on les attaques les nuits
avec des sons mystérieux on pensait que
c'était une arme ultrasonique me suis
déjà réveillé avec un mal de tête
tellement fort le matin que j'ai pensé
que j'allais en est malade tellement la
nausée trafford et victimes sont des
diplomates
c'est une bonne politique en exclusivité
on plonge dans l'en quête avec la police
cubaine sous qu'une supposition dans une
enquête de science fiction et en primeur
on vous présente une nouvelle théorie
qui pourrait tout bouleverser ici marie
maude denis
bienvenue à enquête
[Musique]
entre la fin de 2016 et l'hiver 2010 9
la capitale de cuba est le théâtre de la
plus étrange des épidémies
toutes les victimes sont des diplomates
ou des membres de leur famille certains
entendent des bruits mystérieux la nuit
le symptôme se multiplient mon de tête
nausées et cette demande est très très
fort trois quatre fois dans la même nuit
qui avait du sang partout
maux de tête troubles de l'équilibré de
la vision vomissements acouphènes perte
auditive
le mal ne frappe que des canadiens et
des américains
comme si leur nationalité les désignait
comme s'ils étaient ciblés depuis trois
pays cuba les états unis et le canada
ont mobilisé une armée d'agents de
renseignement de policiers et
scientifique pour découvrir les causes
et conséquences du syndrome de la havane
à ce jour personne qui perd chronique
oui comme on souffrait de saignements de
nez qu'on ne pouvait expliquer trois ou
quatre fois par jour voire wimbée cet
homme ne veut pas être identifié et
parle sous le pseudonyme d'haleine il
est le premier diplomate canadien à cuba
avoir été touché voisin américain est
venu me voir et il m'a invité à prendre
une marche avec c'est une crise aux
victimes sans visage ni l'identité des
canadiens ni celle des américains n'ont
été rendus publics
cette entrevue exclusive à radio canada
a été réalisée en 2018 weeding il m'a
raconté qu'il entendait des bruits mais
nous n'avions rien entendu avant le 1er
juin
lors de cette nuit à landis est
ressentie bombardé par une force
extérieure sous faure qei et souffrait
de fortes nausées
3h10 du matin j'étais couché lorsque ce
bruit m'a réveillé cet effort
extrêmement forts comme un grincement de
métal
cela a durée de vingt à trente secondes
puis ça s'est arrêté à la fin quand les
notes étaient très basses j'ai eu envie
de vomir même que c'est au même moment
mon fils s'est mis à saigner du nez deux
jours plus tard
allen est évacué vers miami c'est ici
que le diplomate canadien sa famille
sont examinés par le docteur michael
offer nicky hayden qui toutes ces
personnes se plaignaient de bruit très
fort hood une sensation de pression et
ados furie prochain ancien médecin
militaire de la us navy michael rafer
possède les accréditations nécessaires
pour mener des recherches touchant à la
sécurité nationale
il est le premier cliniciens recueillir
les témoignages à chaud des premières
victimes américaines comme canadienne
des bus lorsqu'elle se déplaçait dans la
maison le bruit les suivait dès qu'il
ouvrait la porte
le bruit c'est c'était très ciblée voilà
les particularités de ce bruit
ce sont ces premières observations qui
suggère l'idée d' attaques des attaques
acoustique
c'était très solide sérieux parce que
c'était une chose extraordinaire en fait
extraordinaire
lorsque la crise a éclaté en avril 2017
josefina vidal était responsable du
dossier délicat entre tous pour les
cubains celui de la normalisation des
relations avec les états unis
aujourd'hui ambassadrice de cuba à
ottawa elle se souvient du moment où
cette histoire a commencé
on a été les premières personnes à
recevoir les rapports de l'ambassade des
états unis à cuba
à ce moment là les chargés d'affaires
nous approcher et il nous a dit que les
diplomates étaient la cible d'un attaque
conscient de la gravité du dossier deux
pays à l'ancienne des plus vastes
enquêtes de son histoire
nous avons réunis à la havane
les chefs de l'enquète policière cubaine
pour la première fois ils ont accepté
d'accompagner une équipe de journalistes
sur les lieux de ses présumées attaques
et de commenter leurs investigations
c'est un accès exceptionnel d'aussi est
encore chaud une dernière victime un
canadien a été signalé voici quelques
mois seulement en décembre 2018
[Musique]
nous menons une enquête qui est toujours
le colonel ramiro ramires et le chef de
la sécurité du corps diplomatique pour
lui plus que pour quiconque l'hypothèse
même d' attaques en plein coeur du
quartier des ambassades était de la plus
grande importance
je ne pouvais pas croire qu'il y avait
eu des problèmes ou des difficultés dans
cette zone parce que c'est une zone
sécurité maximale des maximas et le
quartier où habitait le chef de la
révolution cubaine à la casse'
[Musique]
le quartier de fidèles plusieurs
milliers de personnes des diplomates et
leurs familles habitent ici il faudrait
beaucoup de complicité pour que
d'éventuels attaquants si active et que
tout le monde ferme les yeux
en plus des patrouilles policières des
caméras de surveillance regarde partout
des gardes de sécurité sont affectés à
plusieurs résidences
sur le terrain la direction des
opérations et confiée au colonel roberto
hernández et à son adjoint le lieutenant
colonel josé à la seringue
c'est une enquête très complexe
formation parce qu'on nous a seulement
transmis l'information longtemps après
les événements parfois même des mois
après les faits une culture du secret
entoure la faire dès le début
rapidement ils sont confrontés aux
difficultés d'enquêté au sein du corps
diplomatique
selon plusieurs sources certaines
victimes sont des agents de
renseignement n'avons pas pu interroger
les présumées victimes au moment des
incidents
qui plus est dans la plupart des cas les
ambassades canadiennes et américains
n'ont tout simplement pas alerté la
police cubaine
canada le canada a déclaré avoir vu
douze ou treize victimes mais nous avons
seulement été avisés de 4k
un silence que le canada n'a jamais
expliqué malgré nos demandes d'entrevue
au ministère des affaires mondiales
il n'y a pas une coopération efficace
entre les pays où être pas ici
le cas des diplomates canadiens laisse
tout le monde perplexe
aucun autre pays sauf les états unis ne
semblent touchés il y à bien entre les
etats-unis et cuba conflit historique
mais avec le canada c'est plutôt le
contraire
en 1976 le canada de pierre trudeau a
été le premier pays occidental à briser
l isolement de cuba alors que depuis
quinze ans de pays de la révolution
communiste de fidel castro était sous
embargo américain pour les cubains la
relation avec le canada est privilégiée
entre toutes nos relations politiques
diplomatiques historique avec les états
unis le canada sont différents vous
serez capable de faire une chose
pareille aux canadiens des attaques
contre le canada à la havane paraissent
donc invraisemblable avec les états unis
n'est guère plus plausible la crise
survient en effet un moment névralgique
quelques mois auparavant barack obama en
fin de mandat a rétabli les ponts avec
cuba après plus d'un demi-siècle
l'embargo est en partie levé
sonora mais les présumées attaques ont
donné des munitions à ceux qui aux états
unis pourrait revenir en arrière
celles ci ont débuté pendant la
transition entre deux présidences
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
le nouveau président s'est toujours
déclarée hostile au rapprochement initié
par son prédécesseur industry pour cuba
tout s'effondre les ententes signées
avec obama sont déchirés des diplomates
cubains sont expulsés de washington le
gouvernement américain des conseils à
ses citoyens de se rendre à cuba cet
événement a été politisée par les
gouvernements des états unis qui a
décidé d'utiliser ces problèmes là comme
une justification pour prendre des
mesures contre les bars
malheureusement ça s'est passé comme ça
et si les fameuses attaques sonore
venait des insectes la suite dans un
instant au début de la crise qui ne
semblait touché que des américains
ceux ci ont traité les présumées
attaques comme un secret militaire mais
le 23 avril 2010 7,7 pays à nice dont le
canada sont officiellement informé
aussitôt l'ambassade canadienne à la
havane relaie l'information à ottawa les
incidents confirmés concernent
uniquement des diplomates américains à
cuba
il est dans notre intérêt d'en apprendre
plus sur cette menace
[Musique]
karine fausse chef de la section
politique et numéro deux de l'ambassade
canadienne à cuba est la tête de pont
entre les deux capitales washington est
aussi dans le circuit de ces échanges
qui nous ont été transmis sous forme
sévèrement caviar b nous savons que les
états unis ont évacué certains de leurs
employés
ils ont été très disciplinés les
américains les maisons se vidait les
unes après les autres et ils ne nous
disait rien nous l'appellerons claudine
un autre pseudonyme
elle est aussi au nombre des présumées
victimes canadiennes moi j'ai souvenir
d'avoir entendu ces sons d'entendre un
bruit du d'une machine un bruit
métallique provenant du fond du jardin
[Musique]
je me suis déjà réveillé avec un mal de
tête tellement fort le matin que j'ai
pensé que j'allais en est malade
tellement la nausée des fortement avec
l'apparition de cas canadien des
courriels diplomatique en forme d'appel
à l'aide parts de la havane vers ottawa
la havane demande assistance présence de
symptômes semblables à ceux du personnel
américain
les canadiens se multiplient c'est une
affaire digne d'un roman d'espionnage
un mal étrange à frapper des diplomates
en poste à cuba
l'afer est devenue publique et politique
fondatrice avec washington
une commission sénatoriale est créé au
début de 2010 huit sénateurs marco rubio
leaders de la communauté cubaine ou
américaines en assure la présidence
d'entrée c'est une occasion pour le
lobby anti castristes des états unis de
passer à l'attaqué
au banc des accusés conscient de la
gravité de la situation
cuba joue la carte de la transparence et
va jusqu'à inviter le fbi américain et
la gendarmerie royale du canada à venir
enquêter sur son territoire l'aide de
cuba est appréciée car une force numéro
deux de l'ambassade canadienne semble
reconnaître les efforts de la police
cubaine mais celle ci n'est pas
autorisée à pénétrer sur les propriétés
des résidences diplomatiques considéré
selon des conventions internationales
comme extraterritoriale
les enquêteurs cubains vont se rabattre
sur les cubains avec le dieu le gist
alida mercedes soares nous sommes
retournés dans les quartiers touchés
nous n'avions pas accès aux victimes
nous avons donc travaillé sur le terrain
avec les gens qui habitaient où
travaillait dans les environs là où on a
rapporté ses présumées attaques
acoustique se pointe en attaque côté
gauche comme les diplomates se
plaignaient de perte auditive
madame soares a évalué louis de ces
travailleurs locaux jardinier domestique
ou gardienne sécurité nous avons examiné
24 personnes et parmi ces 24
nous n'avons trouvé que deux cas de
traumatisme acoustique mais après
enquête nous avons pu démontrer que ces
deux personnes étaient souvent exposés
au bruit dans leur milieu de travail
l'enquète et élargi aux hôpitaux de lave
la santé publique n'a trouvé aucun
rapport sur des personnes s'étant
présentés aux hôpitaux avec des
symptômes tels que ceux déclarés par les
diplomates
en somme les cubains semble épargnée et
pour ajouter à l'étrangeté de la sphère
des cas continuent de s'accumuler chez
les canadiens et les américains pendant
même que l' enquête se déroule éclate
surveillance des diplomates les façons
intensité maximale au printemps 2017
on recense 16 victimes il y en aura
bientôt 40
en courte enquête surgit un nouvel
élément en plus des résidences
diplomatiques des attaques elle déguise
surviennent dans des hôtels de l'en
avant
comme ici à l'hôtel cap prix ou deux
diplomates américains ont affirmé avoir
subi des attaques la nuit alors qu'ils
se trouvaient dans des chambres une
onzième l'autre au 16e étage or il n'ya
au tour aucun d'édifices en hauteur d'où
un rayon aurait pu être dirigée à
l'hôtel national theatre une autre
présumée attaque les conditions ne
semblent guère plus propice les pétales
ok les responsables américains nous ont
déclaré que le diplomate se trouvait
dans la chambre
823 quand il a subi une supposée attaque
acoustique attaquer comme vous pouvez le
voir ce serait difficile de se déplacer
ici avec une arme ou une grosse pièce
d'équipement sans être vu plus haut à
l'extérieur se trouve une terrasse avec
vue sur les chambres 7 on est très bien
protégé par cette porte qui est toujours
fermé et par deux caméras de sécurité
de l'autre côté il y a une autre caméra
on est tout seul endroit où on aurait pu
tenter une attaque mais ce n'est pas
possible à cause de la sécurité dans cet
endroit
et par là en face c'est la mer
[Musique]
en pleine crise l'ambassade des états
unis remet à josefina vidal ce qui est
présenté comme une pièce à conviction le
son enregistré par une victime sur son
téléphone
immédiatement on a passé cette
information un haut responsable de l
enquête
cuban
ces enregistrements sont remis à yamilee
gonsalez sanchez qui a dirigé les
recherches sur l'environnement le jour
comme la nuit elle et ses collègues ont
capté tous les sont possibles à
proximité des résidences diplomatiques
au tempo de la rochelle balle
lp vous pouvez entendre maintenant le
chant des oiseaux
mais pendant la nuit on peut entendre le
chant d'une espèce de grillons connu
dans cette région et qui émet un son
particulier dès le mois d'octobre 2010
est l'équipe de yamilé gonzalez annonce
que ces enregistrements ne sont rien
d'autre que des bruits d'un set
il faudra cependant attendre plus d'un
an en janvier 2019 pour que des
entomologistes américains et
britanniques confirment cette trouvaille
est identifié le coupable de grillons à
queue courte design cuba n'a jamais
affirmé que des lésions auditives ou
cérébrale avait été causée par des
grillons le neurologue mitchell valdez
sosa et le chef scientifique de
l'enquète cubaine mode des boys en dlc
sont dérangeants ont été perçues comme
des attaques hors des pistes
mais ils sont désormais expliquer par
les griots des exploits et coty mitchell
valdés ne cache pas son incrédulité face
à des scénarios d'armes digne d'un roman
fantastique supra reconnaître les faits
mais je ne peux pas accepter des
allégations sans faits surtout si elles
vont à l'encontre de la science reconnu
gaudens tarbes ossun à cuba comme
partout dans le monde
on s'était interrogée sur la nature
d'une arme nouveau genre qui puisse
expliquer les phénomènes rapporté à la
havane
les armes acoustique connues comme celle
ci at les ailes rade sont utilisés pour
contrôler les foules
elles sont souvent lourdes et difficiles
à transporter en plus elles ont besoin
d'une grande quantité d'énergie et on ne
peut pas les dissimuler facilement et
elles émettent des ultrasons qui ne
peuvent pas traverser facilement les
obstacles comme des murs ou même des
vitres les armes qui utilise des micro
ondes sont aussi encombrants comme on pu
voir dans cette expérience d'un
fabricant militaire américain la
sensation de brûlure sur la peau est
instantané une réaction qui ne
correspond pas du tout aux récits des
diplômes a ses limites techniques ont
suggéré l'existence d'une arme inconnus
voire même prototype secret l'américain
michael rohr qui a participé aux
analyses de la défense américaine
soutient tout de même l'idée d'une forme
d'agression sharks
nous n'utilisons jamais le matin oui
l'aune de sa note chaque we know nous ne
savons pas s'il ya eu attaque savons que
ces gens ont été touchés par une force
externe quelconque mais nous le savons
ni comment ni pourquoi tu croises mais
en fait deux ans et demi après le début
de la faire après des rapports d'experts
présenté aux états unis en commission
sénatoriale personne à ce jour n'a pu
expliquer comment et avec quelles armes
de telles attaques auraient pu avoir
lieu de tels prétendues armes
échapperait aux lois de la physique
l'idée d'une arme capable de traverser
les murs et cibler une seule personne
comme le prétendent certains diplomates
ne tient pas la route scientifique guide
son mari
[Musique]
au sein de la diplomatie canadienne
pendant les premières semaines de la
crise l'information circule seulement
aux échelons supérieurs de la mission de
la havane et du ministère des affaires
mondiales à ottawa mais pendant presque
deux mois des fonctionnaires canadiens
sont tenues dans l'ignorance des
victimes en ont gros sur le coeur
et puis allons donner toujours à essayer
de quémander pour des chances qui qui
nous sommes donc se bat pour la danse
même entre nous les consignes étaient
n'en parlez pas à vos collègues
alors oui on a été très seul mais on
accepter cette solitude parce qu'on
pensait quelque part qu'on serait épaulé
qu'on serait accompagné qu'on aurait
l'aide du gouvernement parce qu on a
réalisé qu'on était seule pour vrai pour
nos soins pour trouver des réponses pour
trouver des solutions et c'est comme ça
que c'est développer une solidarité
ensemble cinq diplomates canadiens ont
intenté une poursuite collective de 28
millions de dollars contre leur
employeur
le ministère des affaires mondiales du
canada à l'égard négligence dans le
traitement de leur situation et celle de
leur famille les victimes disent avoir
vécu un long chemin de croix diagnostic
des centaines d'examens de tester de
traitement des eaux ont fait voyager
entre la floride et la pennsylvanie
ottawa et la nouvelle écosse avec comme
enjeu leur santé mais aussi leur
crédibilité de perdre le tiers des
patients se sont plaints de perte
auditive
mais quand on prend des mesures
objectives de leur audition il n'y a pas
de perte
le neurologue américain dans ce film qui
a couvert cette histoire pour le
magazine scientific american fait partie
des sceptiques
rien de crédible dans tout ça de plus
près cette théorie selon laquelle un
faisceau d'énergie peut traverser les
murs suivre les personnes à l'intérieur
des chambres dire que certains vont
entendre quelque chose dans une pièce
plus d'autres rien du tout ce n'est pas
scientifique
toute allégation extraordinaire exige
des preuves extraordinaires et dans ce
cas il n'y avait aucune preuve
en fait une simple preuve suffirait à
commencer par un diagnostic clair ce qui
est loin d'être évident a obtenu le
département d'état américain a confié à
une équipe de chercheurs de l'université
de pennsylvanie
un examen plus approfondi tous victimes
canadiennes
insatisfaite des premières évaluations
faites au canada se sont aussi rendus à
leurs frais à cette clinique américaine
en avril 2018
le diagnostic tombe les victimes
présentent une constellation de
symptômes qui sont apparentés a su d'une
commotion cérébrale mais sans qu'il y
ait eu de choc
du jamais vu semestre et c'est un
mystère nous n'avons aucune expérience
de symptômes de commotion son choc
quelle autre sorte d'exposition pourrait
créer cela nous ne savons pas winona ces
liquides de dogo smit qui propose la
première définition scientifique du
syndrome de la havane dans le journal of
american medical association journal
produire ce ne serait pas le résultat
d'une exposition naturelle
croupissant il est possible que ça se
reproduise un jour ce n'est guère il
faut être prêt
la publication des résultats des
chercheurs de pennsylvanie soulève un
tollé dans la communauté scientifique
des neurologues de plusieurs pays
écrivent au journal médical américain
pour dénoncer la méthodologie de l'étude
les seuils de l'analyse était si peu
rigoureux que chez n'importe quel groupe
de patients plus de la moitié des tests
auraient été positifs
cette étude a été critiqué par des
scientifiques du monde entier
il s'agit d'une multitude de différents
malaises
certains ont des problèmes cognitifs
d'autres des troubles du sommeil
certains ont des problèmes auditifs mais
la plupart non on prend des affections
très différentes l'une de l'autre on les
regroupe
et on appelle ça un syndrome ce n'est
pas un syndrome son intérêt à cuba une
enquête policière alimente également le
scepticisme en octobre 2018
la gendarmerie royale du canada enquête
conjointement avec la police locale
lorsque survient un nouveau cas l'un de
ces cas où nous avons enquêté ensemble
est celui d'une diplomate qui vivaient
près de l'ambassade de l'angleterre
là est la non fictif était littéralement
voisine de l'imposante délégation
britannique
lorsqu'elle s'est plaint de malaises
qu'elle associé à un bruit aucun
symptôme ni incident similaire m'avait
été rapportés par les britanniques
exceptionnellement cette fois grâce à la
présence de la police canadienne le chef
enquêteur cubain va pouvoir lui aussi
l'interroger c'est un cas intéressant
car cette diplomate pratiquer la plongée
la natation des sports dans le genre le
5 octobre
nous l'avons interrogé en compagnie d'un
médecin cubain s'est vite
il lui a dit ce que vous avez est un bar
ou traumatismes liés à votre pratique de
la plongée
ce qui peut empirer à cause de la
pression lorsque vous montez dans un
avion après celles affectées or la
veille elle était rentré du mexique
les informations que nous avons
recueillies à cuba dont 17 airplay nous
avons entendu parler de beaucoup de
symptômes très différents ils sont
souvent variable d'un individu à un
autre leur cours qui peuvent remonter
avant des séjours des victimes d'un cube
en serions nous à présence de mal
imaginaire
[Musique]
après la pause la crédibilité des
victimes va être sérieusement remise en
question
[Musique]
pour comprendre il faut tenir compte du
climat dans lequel cette affaire
commente revenons en arrière en avril
2010 m
alors qu'aucun canadien à la havane
encore eu vent d attaque présumée
survenue chez les diplomates des états
unis un voisin américains frappent à la
porte d'haleine celui qui deviendra la
première victime canadienne
il m'a proposé d'aller marcher ce que
j'ai trouvé curieux car ce n'était pas
un ami mais je savais que nous maison
était sous écoute et j'ai compris qu'il
voulait parler
c'est dans cette atmosphère de romans
d'espionnage que ce voisin foetale une
révélation plutôt qu en en marchant il
m'a parlé de ce qui se passait à
l'ambassade américaine en détail des
symptômes
il se disait fâché que son gouvernement
ne veuille pas informé le nôtre ils
voulaient nous avertir parce que nous
étions voisins
peu de temps après à l'année sa
conjointe fortin lien avec des malaises
qui dressant depuis quelques temps en
particulier des maux de tête et il ya
ces saignements de nez qui affectent
leur fils aîné depuis quelque temps
lorsqu il informa basse add on lui
ordonne de n'en parler à personne
l'information ne circule pas moins entre
les capitales plusieurs des symptômes
sont semblables à ceux de stress extrême
les premiers courriels diplomatique du
canada laisse entendre que ces symptômes
pourraient être reliés au stress
il est possible que la peur d'être ciblé
puisse entraîner des effets sur la santé
mentale
[Musique]
la peur d'être attaqués cette tentative
d'explication formulée dès le début par
karine fausse va devenir pour plusieurs
la plus plausible
devant l'absence de preuve d' attaque
plusieurs grandes enquêtes
journalistiques penche désormais vers
l'hypothèse d'une congrès avant tout
psychologique
serions nous en présence d'une hystérie
de masse sans avec une journée je ne dis
pas que ces gens mentent mais la mémoire
humaine est très facile et il dit ce qui
se passe à cuba
c'est l'équivalent de se réveiller la
nuit d'entendre un bruit suspect de
croire que c'est un fantôme
et d'appeler au spécialiste des
phénomènes paranormaux alors qu'il
aurait fallu appeler le plombier
nous avons joint en nouvelle zélande
robert bartholomew ce sociologue est
l'un des plus grands spécialistes de
l'hystérie de masse il a été un des
premiers à proposer une explication
d'origine psychologique au syndrome de
la havane
nous disposons d'assez de données pour
déterminer ce qui s'est passé c'est une
affection psychologique de masse et onze
partant d'hystérie collective
nous n'avons pas cette expression mais
l'idée de croire à une attaque est un
phénomène sociologique sociaux à dire
aïe 500 postale
si les gens croient qu'ils sont attaqués
que leur gouvernement leur dit qu'ils
sont attaqués et qu'ils sont évacués
comme s'il s'agissait d'un champ de
bataille alors tout symptôme sera
amplifié c'est évidemment une théorie
réconfortante pour les cubains il faut
dire que la séquence des événements
vient la renforcer we do not dead m
après que l'ambassade américaine est
officiellement informé ses employés
ainsi que d'autres ambassades les
signalements d' attaques présumées ont
augmenté en flèche des questions
quelques jours avant la conclusion de
notre reportage ces diplomates canadiens
ont accepté de nous rencontrer
ils sont indignés par ces théories qui
les discrédite
c'est blessant et surtout ce qui était
le plus dur à accepter dans la situation
c'est que ça n'était pas basé comme une
analyse qui arrivé à ces conclusions
une analyse rigoureuse de notre état de
santé mentale qui amènerait à une
conclusion médicale que notre problème
est un problème d'hystérie collective
non le pont il a été fait parce qu'on
n'avait pas d'explication
un des cas canadien va embrouiller
encore un peu plus cette piste d'un mâle
d'origine psychologique c'est celui de
40 fosses celle là même qui en mai 2010
est suggérée dans des courriels de
l'ambassade que les victimes souffraient
de symptômes psychosomatiques
elle va changer de perspective un mois
plus tard le 14 juin 2010 est le centre
de direction de la protection
diplomatique a reçu un appel
téléphonique d'un madame car en face qui
demandait ma présence chez elle a dit
qu'elle avait des maux de tête et
d'autres mondes et qu'elle centea
c'est le seul cas où à cause de cette
attelle la police cubaine a pu se rendre
dans une résidence au moment des faits
ou en d'autres
selon elle il y avait un bruit étrange à
côté de la piscine et cela l'a dérangé
et l état affectaient le gardien de
sécurité a même vu son mari qui
cherchait quelque chose et lui a demandé
qu'est-ce qui se passe celui ci lui a
répondu elle dit qu'elle entend quelque
chose mais moi je n'entends rien on a eu
le réflexe de demander à l'un de nos
gardes de sécurité postés dans sa maison
d'enregistrer ce qui se passait à partir
de son cellulaire
cet élément de preuve a également été
analysée par nos experts
mais il ne les considérait pas dangereux
pour la santé humaine
c'est comme si nous étions dans une
enquête de science fiction
madame phase serait donc une sceptiques
confondues elle ne s'est pas joint
dassieu ses collègues qui poursuivent
aujourd'hui le gouvernement canadien
elle a quitté cuba peu tendre et cette
nuit du 14 juin au ministère des
affaires mondiales
on nous a répondu qu'on ne la
connaissais pas des sources proches du
dossier assurent qu'elle a joint aux
services de sécurité du gouvernement
canadien
michael offer de l'université de miami à
qui nous avons parlé pendant l'été
insiste pourparlers d'adhésion objective
en particulier des problèmes
vestibulaire qui touche l'equilibre deux
organes de l'oreille interne paraissent
affectés est-ce que vos conclusions
contredisent l'idée qu'il s'agit d'un
phénomène psychogénétique yacé oui ce
sont des conclusions objectives comme je
vous ai déjà dit on ne peut pas falsifié
ni un résultat positif ni un résultat
négatif est que ces tests ne peuvent pas
être falsifié les blessures subies par
ces 25 victimes nous indique qu'il est
arrivé quelque chose quelque chose mais
quoi
la réponse encore inédite pourrait bien
se trouver dans ce document canadiens
dont nous avons obtenu copie
oubliez tout ce que vous avez entendu
jusqu'ici
[Musique]
pendant que nous enquêtions à la havane
washington et ottawa
le mystère a généré un foisonnement de
théories du complot
cuba posséderait t-il une nouvelle arme
secrète une faction veut-elle saboter
leur rapprochement avec les états unis
la cia et les russes
les cubaines miami opposants anti castro
tous y sont passés
y compris les chinois surtout depuis que
des symptômes similaires ont été
rapportés chez des diplomates américains
en poste en chine malgré eux les
diplomates canadiens se sont retrouvés
dans un tourbillon géopolitique
planétaire
mais si l'explication était beaucoup
plus terre à terre
c'est du moins ce qu'avance ce rapport
encore confidentiel transmis en juillet
au gouvernement du canada et dont
enquête révèle pour la première fois les
principales conclusions
ce pourrait bien être un coup de théâtre
dans cette saga qui dure depuis deux ans
et demi
en 2018 le gouvernement du canada a
demandé à des scientifiques de
l'université dalhousie en nouvelle
écosse d'évaluer en profondeur la santé
de ces diplomates revenus de cuba 26
chercheurs du prime reaper center ont
été associés à cette étude la plus
poussée à ce jour sa direction a été
confiée aux neurologues allonnes
friedman le diagnostic est catégorique
le séjour à la havane a causé chez ces
gens des lésions cérébrales qui
n'existait pas auparavant
pour la première fois des individus ont
été testés avant et après leur mission
diplomatique
le gouvernement canadien a sagement
décidé à compter de 2018 d'envoyer à
halifax tout diplomate en partance pour
cuba pour une évaluation cérébrale
nous en avons testé avant et six mois
après et nous avons vu des changements
au cerveau est un muscle les lésions
cérébrales inverse si évidente que pour
le docteur friedman l'hypothèse de
l'hystérie de masse ne résiste pas à
l'analyse
notre clinique lui noté deux semaines ni
en fonction des résultats cliniques ni
par les symptômes ni par l'imagerie du
cerveau
notre conclusion est que ce n'est pas du
style in may 6 note mass hysteria on a
même procédé à l'autopsié du chien
dalhem dont le comportement c'était
complètement transformé à cuba
[Musique]
résultat son cerveau présentait des
lésions dans les mêmes régions du cortex
que chez les humains
il n'était sûrement pas atteint 10
terrine masse ces découvertes ont mis
l'équipe de friedman sur une nouvelle
piste
c'est dommage au cerveau sont typiques
de ceux causés par des agents
neurotoxiques utilisé dans la fumigation
fin lorsque les symptômes sont apparus
en 2016 et 2017
le gouvernement cubain a lancé une
campagne contre les ica et a fait des
fumigations sur toute l'île en
particulier à la havane et dans les
villes dans les rues avec des camions
dans les maisons
c'était une opération militaire contre
les tigres
pendant la même période avons nous
appris l'ambassade du canada à cuba à
augmenter voire parfois quintuplé ses
propres opérations de fumigation des
résidences toujours pour contrer délicat
aurait-on empoisonné des fonctionnaires
en voulant les protéger les deux sources
combinés ont certainement exposer les
diplomates de manière excessive aux
mureaux toxines dans le tocsin dans les
derniers jours nous avons tout de même
recueilli des premières réactions dont
celle du chef scientifique de l'enquète
cubaine il s'agit d'une hypothèse
scientifique plausible qui n'est pas
fondée sur de mystérieuses attaques ce
que les canadiens ont rejeté ceci donne
un point de départ solide pour d'autres
recherches par les cubains et par les
canadiens le neurologue américain josh
fields crois que les chercheurs de
dalhousie saute un peu vite aux
conclusions
cette étude a le mérite de poser un
diagnostic de manière rationnelle
plutôt que de présumer qu on a affaire à
une arme fantastique
leur hypothèse d'une possible toxicité
des pesticides est plausible mais elle
n'est pas vraiment prouvé mes propres
recherches portent sur les effets de ce
type de neurotoxines sur le cerveau
penser seulement au temps qu'il a fallu
pour prouver que fumer la cigarette
cause le cancer
la nouvelle théorie avancée par les
scientifiques canadiens ne satisfera pas
tout le monde
comment expliquer par exemple ces cas
rapportés par les états unis qui
seraient survenus dans des chambres
d'hôtel ni pourquoi seulement des
américains et des canadiens semblent
avoir été touchés et les cubains qui
travaillait dans ses résidences
ils n'ont certes pas été évalué en
tenant compte de cette nouvelle théorie
l'étude canadienne a au moins le mérite
d'être plausible et terre à terre et
elle ne relève ni d'une psychose de
guerre froide ni de la science fiction
[Musique]
ce sera intéressant de suivre les
développements dans l' enquête sur le
mystère de la vanne et parlant de
développement la semaine dernière vous
vous souvenez vous a présenté un
reportage sur les déboires du traversier
fo gauthier et bien dès le lendemain le
gouvernement du québec annoncé une
enquête de la vérificatrice générale au
nom de toute l'équipe merci beaucoup
d'avoir été là ils reviennent ils la
semaine prochaine pour une autre enquête
je
[Musique]